.
AND THAT IS NOT EVEN THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE THING, GUYS.
HE IS NOW TOP 10 ON THE NEW YORK
TIMES BESTSELLER LIST WITH HIS
NEW BOOK.
WHAT IS UP?
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
CARMELO: NUMBER SEVEN.
NUMBER SEVEN TO BE EXACT.
CHRIS: BY THE WAY, GOT TO GET
THAT IN THERE, THAT IS THE
JERSEY NUMBER.
I LOVE IT.
CARMELO: ABSOLUTELY.
ALLIE: MILO, CONGRATULATIONS, BY
THE WAY.
I KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR BOOK
TOUR.
HERE YOU ARE TRYING TO GEAR UP
FOR YOUR 19 SEASON.
YOU ARE ON A QUEST TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP.
ALL THE WHILE, YOU ARE ALSO AN
AUTHOR.
HOW DO YOU BALANCE IT?
CARMELO: ACTUALLY, IT IS EASY.
IT IS EASY.
BASKETBALL COMES FIRST.
THAT IS A NO-BRAINER.
EVERYTHING ELSE AFTER THAT IS
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES.
AS LONG AS YOU ARE ABLE TO STAY
SOLID AND LOCK IN ON WHAT YOU
NEED TO LOCK IN ON, YOU HAVE
TIME AND YOU HAVE ROOM TO DO
OTHER THINGS.
CHRIS: MILO, BIG GAME HAS A
SMILE ON HIS FACE BECAUSE I
THINK HE IS JUST HAPPY YOU ARE
FINALLY HERE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE THINKING?
JAMES: I AM.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES: I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH A
FEW YEARS BACK WHEN MITCH
KUPCHAK WAS THE G.M. TO SIT IN
ON A LITTLE PRESENTATION.
THINGS DID NOT WORK OUT THE WAY
THEY HAD BUT HE IS HERE NOW AND
THAT IS THE ONLY THING THAT
MATTERS.
I HAVE A QUESTION BECAUSE AFTER
15 OR 16, 17 YEARS, PEOPLE TRY
TO WRITE YOU OFF AND SAY, OK,
YOU ARE AT THE END OF YOUR
CAREER AND THEN HE POPPED UP IN
PORTLAND AND I WAS LIKE, I KNEW
IT!
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES: TALK ABOUT THAT, MAN.
TALK ABOUT HOW IN YOUR MIND YOU
KNOW.
BECAUSE VETERAN PLAYERS HAVE
WISDOM.
THEY MIGHT NOT BE 22 ANYMORE,
BUT TALK ABOUT HOW THAT HAS
EVOLVED FROM BEING THE CARMELO
WHO WAS A DYNAMIC SCORERS TO NOW
BEING THE X FACTOR AT THIS POINT
OF YOUR CAREER.
CARMELO: WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
GAME.
WE ARE ALL STUDENTS OF THE GAME.
IF YOU KNOW THE HISTORY OF THE
GAME, NOBODY STAYED THE SAME.
THERE WILL ALWAYS BE ADJUSTMENT
YOU HAVE TO MAKE.
YOU WILL ALWAYS HAVE TO ADAPT TO
CERTAIN SITUATIONS, CERTAIN
RULES.
BECAUSE A BIG PART OF THAT IS
THE NARRATIVE OF AS YOU GET
OLDER, YOU LOSE SOMETHING.
FOR ME, IT NEVER WAS A
BASKETBALL THING WITH ME.
I ALWAYS BELIEVED IN MYSELF.
I ALWAYS KNEW AND KNOW WHAT I
CAN DO WITH THE BASKETBALL -- ON
THE BASKETBALL COURT.
I RELY ON MY WORK ETHIC, BEING
IN THE GYM, BEING KNOWLEDGEABLE
IN THE GAME, SHARPENING MY
MENTAL.
I THINK ONCE I GOT TO THAT
POINT, BASKETBALL JUST BECAME --
IT WAS MORE EASY FOR ME.
IT WAS MORE EFFICIENT FOR ME
BECAUSE I PUT THOSE 10,000 HOURS
IN.
I PUT THE 20,000 HOURS IN.
YOU KNOW, BEHIND THE DOORS,
BEHIND THE SCENES AT NIGHT, IN
THE MORNING, WORKING OUT WHEN
NOBODY IS THERE.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT.
THEY MAY HEAR IT BUT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT TAKES.
FOR ME TO BE TAKEN AWAY FROM THE
GAME FOR THAT YEAR, SOME CHANGE,
IT REJUVENATING ME.
IT GAVE ME A NEWFOUND PASSION
ABOUT THE GAME FROM A WHOLE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE
EXPERIENCING NOW AND WHAT YOU
HAVE EXPERIENCED WHEN I WAS IN
PORTLAND IS THAT PASSION.
JAMES: AMEN.
CHRIS: WELL SAID.
WELL SAID.
SPREADING THE FLOOR IN TODAY'S
NBA IS KEY.
CAREER-BEST FROM 342%.
HOW MUCH WORK -- MELO, I AM GLAD
YOU BROUGHT UP THE WORD FLOOR
EFFICIENCY.
HOW MUCH WORK DO YOU PUT INTO
THAT PART OF YOUR GAME?
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR YOU HAVE
GOTTEN MORE EFFICIENT.
CARMELO: YOU HAVE TO.
THE GAME IS GETTING YOUNGER.
[LAUGHTER]
CARMELO: YOU HAVE TO STILL
FINE TUNE THOSE SKILLS.
THOSE KNIVES IN THE DORA, YOU
GOT TO KEEP THEM SHARP.
FOR ME, I AM ALWAYS TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO STAY SHARP,
STAY AHEAD OF THE GAME, STAY
AHEAD OF THE COMPETITION, HOW TO
BE SMARTER, HOW TO UTILIZE
THINGS DIFFERENTLY.
LIKE YOU SAID EARLIER, I AM NOT
22 ANYMORE SO I HAVE TO GO ABOUT
THINGS LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
I HAVE TO THINK THINGS THROUGH
MORE SO NOW THAT I HAD TO WHEN I
WAS 22, WHEN I COULD GO AND JUST
PLAYOFF OF PURE SKILL, TALENT,
AND JUST BEING GREEN AND WRONG.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
I AM BLESSED.
19 YEARS IN THE NBA.
THIS IS THE NBA'S 75TH BIRTHDAY
COMING UP, SO FOR ME TO SAY I
HAVE ALMOST SPENT 19, 20 YEARS
OF THAT, I AM BLESSED.
THAT IS WHAT I HAVE TO SAY.
ALLIE: MELO, WHEN IT COMES TO
WINNING, WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY YOUR
GOAL, IT TAKES A TEAM.
WE TALKED TO THE BIG THREE
ALREADY WHEN IT COMES TO
RUSSELL, A.D., AND LEBRON, AND
EACH HAVE ECHOED THAT SENTIMENT
TODAY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN YOU AND
LEBRON, THE FRIENDSHIP YOU KNOW
GOES BEYOND BASKETBALL.
OBVIOUSLY THE BATTLES OVER THE
YEARS WITH THE TWO OF YOU,
WELL-DOCUMENTED ALWAYS.
THEY HAVE ALWAYS BEEN FUN TO
WATCH.
BUT YOU RECENTLY JUST SAT AT
THIS POINT OF YOUR CAREER, I AM
CURIOUS, THAT YOU NEEDED TO HEAR
DIRECTLY FROM HIM.
WHY WAS THAT IMPORTANT WHEN IT
CAME TO JOINING THE LAKERS?
CARMELO: BECAUSE I KNOW OUR
FRIENDSHIP, I KNOW OUR
BROTHERHOOD THAT WE HAVE, I KNOW
THE CONNECTION THAT WE HAVE.
AND OVER THE YEARS, WE HAVE BEEN
DIPPING AND DABBING, LET'S PLAY
TOGETHER, LET'S DO THIS, LET'S
DO THAT.
BUT IT WAS NOT THAT.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, WHERE WE
BOTH ARE IN OUR CAREERS, I THINK
WE BOTH NEEDED TO HEAR THAT.
I NEEDED TO HEAR "I NEED YOU, I
WANT YOU, LET'S GO."
I NEEDED TO HEAR THAT
AFFIRMATION.
WHEREAS BEFORE, IT WAS JUST, I
THINK THIS WOULD BE COOL, THIS
WOULD BE ILL, LET'S MAKE THIS
HAPPEN.
IT WAS A DIFFERENT FEELING, A
DIFFERENT VIBE AT THIS POINT.
HE IS IN THE BACKGROUND RIGHT
NOW DANCING.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS: SO MANY FUTURE HALL OF
FAMERS ON THIS TEAM.
WHAT IS THE BATTING ORDER?
WHAT IS THE PECKING ORDER?
WHO GETS TO EAT FIRST ON THE
PLANE, VEGAS TRIP?
CARMELO: I AM THE OLDEST BY A
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
THAT IS THE PECKING ORDER RIGHT
THERE.
IT IS THE LEVEL OF RESPECT WE
ALL HAVE FOR EACH OTHER.
THAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
WE RESPECT EACH OTHER, NOT JUST
AS BASKETBALL PLAYERS, BUT AS
MEN.
WHEN YOU HAVE THAT, YOU ARE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE BETTER.
YOU ARE ABLE TO HOLD EACH OTHER
ACCOUNTABLE MORE.
BECAUSE LET'S BE QUITE FRANK,
MAN.
THERE ARE GOING TO BE UPS AND
DOWNS THIS YEAR.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE IT ALL
FIGURED OUT OFF THE TOP.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THAT BUT
THIS IS A LONG JOURNEY.
I WANT TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
LEAPS AND HOOPS AND LOOPS AND
VALLEYS AND HILLS AND MOUNTAINS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GO THROUGH.
I WANT TO EXPERIENCE THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW AT THE END OF THE
DAY, IF WE DO WHAT WE GOT TO DO,
IT WILL MAKE THE JOURNEY THAT
MUCH BETTER.
CHRIS: GREAT STUFF FROM CARMELO
ANTHONY.
WE APPRECIATE YOU.
FROM A GUY THAT HAS AN ITALIAN
MOTHER, 100%, I LOVE YOUR
ITALIAN MEAL REFERENCED THAT YOU
HAD.
CARMELO: I APPRECIATE THAT.
CHRIS: DOES NOT MATTER WHO IS
COOKING IN THE KITCHEN AND HOW
OLD THEY ARE AS LONG AS THE FOOD
IS GREAT.
THAT IS ALL THAT MATTERS.
JAMES: AND A GOOD CIGAR.
-- FOOD TASTES GREAT AND A GOOD
CIGAR.
CHRIS: CIGAR IS ON THE